currently working alongside Kenny Albert
they will be calling the Redskins Giants
game on Sunday because Burkhart is busy
doing some World Series stuff CD how you
doing brother now I'm doing well how
about you guys I think we're doing ok
we've made it through the first hour in
25 minutes relatively unscathed I
haven't checked Twitter yet so you know
that laughs that last bit there where
you don't listen that's kind of been
your only bobble right Charles you got
to save us pal
you know I can't I can't save you you
know you guys get that under control
you've no good teams if you're low pure
love hope you guys are both doing great
we're doing great my friend I know
you've been studying up for that
Redskins Giants game already so let's
let's start with that you know I'm a
huge Redskins fan and I'm not really
buying them as a team that's on their
way to a division title what have you
seen when you study them so far
well I've seen a team that's been I
watched back the CBS broadcast last week
and you know how jacked up they were to
have one out of the Fox inventory
because you know NFC pack to be a fox
game right so they end up with the game
and then watch them one of the great
rivalries and they ended up having a
terrific game but they flashed up a
wonderful graphic I thought it was
really terrific that showed over the
course of time just how average
Washington has been to the record almost
equalizes out you know every time you
stop it somewhere and here they are in
their last 10 games and they're in the
last 20 here the last 30 and essentially
was 500 no matter what you did you know
there wasn't much fluctuation either way
and that's been for them over the last
three years Jay Gruden told me earlier
this year we have a very front running
team and he didn't mean it as a
compliment that has the ability to make
a return in the fourth quarter can come
back like in Aaron Rodgers is on your
side you never think you're out of a
game but they have shown dramatically
when they get out to leads they're hard
to beat if they don't get out to a lead
people beat them and it's showing up
this year just look at the record for
this season and look at how the games
have played out here's where the hook
there's optimism two places one they
strung together back-to-back victories
and significant ones okay beating
Carolina at home and then turn around
beat in Dallas that was big for them
huge and and and then the second part is
the rest of the NFC East is tripping
over itself as well so it could be what
it could bode well for them
i'ma throw in one more to a that
defensive front and the investment they
put in defense over the last couple of
drafts I end free agency I think it's
starting to pay dividends for them they
have three uh Alabama guys on that
defense that are all you know Ryan
Anderson probably the least heralded
actually for the other one just been
playing my shoddy
no you're right you're absolutely right
but drawn pain and Jonathan Allen huge
parts of that defensive line the things
that hindered them the most coming into
this season we're stopping the run and
and running the rock and obviously
they're doing a big plays - they're
doing both of those all right the Giants
wait I'm not gonna ask you the question
everybody's wondering is Eli done I will
ask you it this way what is in New York
what well and I think I think that
basically is the question what's the
biggest problem with that team right now
is it the offensive line that just it's
like a sieve they put money into Nate's
older and not getting the return on
investment he like it's in a lot I
pasted Zach 55 times cases a number of
hips out of be into the Gabby towards a
hundred right no no it's answered putts
about that the guards going to be
actually played fairly well the first
month or so of the season but he's a
rookie he's gonna have his times it is
battled and you know what doesn't help a
rookie guard a rotating block of centers
and it had that down how he else started
the season he gets hurt Neal I think the
second game Greco comes into place oh
they have some more moves they need to
make all right
poley who was diving at center for the
Chargers in 2015 I believe so
rotating group there to help a lucky
guard who relies on center to make sure
it wind up correctly his blocking
schemes here's what's going on and he's
got three guys that he's already played
next to that doesn't help at all
patrocle male that you know they put a
bunch of money into him as a free agent
he was hurt last week but truthfully he
was going to get benched anyway they
were making the move to greco and at
right tackle we know that they tried
Eric flowers we know that didn't work
they tried to shout them no one wanted
to take him they cut him he ends up in
Jacksonville and you're starting you
know Chad wheeler right tackle an
undrafted free agent so yes
it's a long path but it's happening all
different places and now a team that
they had hoped would contend you can
tell by this week with the trading of
Eli Apple the trading of snacks Harrison
that they're open for business that way
and even John Mayer along as the team
probably said this past week at the
owners meeting yeah this is not going to
be a quick fix rebuilt this time here we
are James go Dan Haley on the Rich Eisen
show we got Charles Davis the great
Charles Davis joining us as well hey
Charles can you talk about what that
mood might be with New York man because
again you talk about a team that's you
know struggled to win a game they're
trading away some of their best players
I mean I was absolutely floored that
they traded away snacks cuz again I mean
I know they've been giving up some yards
on the ground but still everyone
recognizes snacks is one of the best
defensive players they got on that team
to trade him away for for what they got
I think it was a fifth round pick I was
blown away by that and I'm sure that
does not sit well with the current
players on that team well you see you
probably have seen the tweets from
Landon Collins and you know Devon Canard
who's in Detroit now play with the
Giants was like yes no I'm sure the
players aren't happy because knacks is
pretty popular there but go back and
look at the numbers of plays his
percentage of plays James okay and
that's and that's gonna tell you a big
reason what about what's going on
yeah she's one of the elite rug
defenders in the game but he's not
playing that much or nearly what you
would expect him to be playing and
coated they're still not stopping the
run you know and that's what he's
supposed to be there to solidify right
in the last but not least it no one's
going to talk about he's got a very
unwieldy contract hmm and for them to
make moves and to get better they had
the abyss of some of that Detroit which
still has designs on getting in it in
the NFC North because don't want to take
it off and just elevated yet not totally
well what have they been really bad at
this year
one being known yeah and that and that
Patricia has been around as a defensive
coordinator
what is his team throughout time big
guys inside who can stop the run and
help them out everywhere else he's kind
of looking at snacks Harrison as an
investment in that to get things going
for his new program in Detroit so it
make sense for both sides in a lot of
ways especially when you're one in six
they're going to be other players are
going to talk about on the huge it goes
read it I mean I'm reading the stuff
getting ready to Norris Jenkins keeps
popping up right Olivier Vernon's name
pops up although I don't see that one is
coming because the way the contract is
structure so I'd be a real surprise and
of course the conversation is when do
they actually make a move with Eli
because last year's regime as you guys
remember they drafted David what Davis
Webb the kid out of Colorado well out
they decide they need to see him late
they need to see another quarterback
late in the season so they bench Eli and
killed the streak of 210 straight starts
but you know he's very proud of and they
start Geno Smith so the first one you
sit down you have your hard conversation
with your your veteran quarterback we're
going nowhere this is what we want to do
and I'm sure they could have come up
with a pretty good deal with him I
really think that I think when they said
we're going to bench you for Geno Smith
that went right out the window
[Applause]
with a plan and and Geno Smith is not a
plan you've got tape on Geno Smith
you've seen him in the league find out
if your rookie can play this year they
drafted Cal well Letta fourth-round kid
out of Richmond he's been inactive every
game so behind the scenes that
to start ramping that up and deciding if
they're going to play him which I think
they have to because they passed on
every quarterback in last year's draft
they gotta find out if they've got into
vestment in law Letta before they go
into next year's draft so when do they
have pull the plug on Eli when do they
have this conversation I think behind
closed doors the the people who run the
team are having that conversation I
think this week's game it's probably
after it's over that conversation ramps
up into high gear no I think you're
probably right and you have Lolita who
you said has been inactive and then you
also have Alex Tanny no no he's not
trickshot artist I had to throw it in
because every time I say Alex candy
people look at me funny and especially
when I'm back home in the Northeast they
go away and I go play played at Monmouth
and they go oh yeah well he played at
Monmouth in Lillet it was it Richmond
certainly not a big time power 5 program
by any stretch of the imagination one
double A versus Division two a little
different might be a just maybe are they
- mama - yeah anyway but and then in any
event it's been interesting to watch and
I hate it for Eli because one thing
about him
we everybody can criticize this and
criticize that that guy's answered the
bell mm-hmm every time and we always
talk about quarterbacking consistency
guys showing up toughness you know
people might not think of Eli's at all
times tough guy how many NFL
quarterbacks answered the Bell 16 games
year in year out it's hard to do I think
he's feel like he's paid the price
Charles for that I feel like he can't
even move around
he 37 was never a great mover to begin
with and when you become 37 you move
even less you need that offensive line
to be better you need things to go well
they were
in Berkeley in the draft choice of
berkeley i don't think you can criticize
in terms of production but they were
hoping he would make the offensive line
better he would help you out the problem
is he's done it to such an extent that
maybe the ball isn't getting down feel
as much as they walk and I know Eli
would look at me and go bro you stand in
the pocket trying to run into everybody
wants to push it downfield remember what
it takes to push it down for you and
they don't have that to upgrade to cadet
right now he could end up saying that to
you in the production meeting
I want to ask you about a friend of
yours somebody who you coached with at
Pacific I believe and that's no not Hugh
Jon Gruden John Curran you go way back
with Jon Gruden you are friends with Jon
Gruden Jon Gruden is having a rough go
of it what is your what is your take on
what is going on in Oakland right now I
really wish I had a good take on it one
of the things that you have with friends
and I know it's different in our
business because sometimes because of
our friendships we get more stuff than
others but I'm not like silver you know
I'm not writing for a living I'm not
breaking stories for a living that sort
of a deal so I'm able to take my
friendship with Jon and keep it right
there I don't ask in these sorts of
things when we talk we don't have those
types of conversations so everything I'm
about to say all right I'm saying as a
person who's observing as an analyst as
a person who's watching the league I
don't know what's going on there I I
could know what the plan is I'd like to
know what's happening the Giants are now
telling us that they're rebuilding right
with the moves that they're making
that's why that can take as it Oakland
is said we're gonna rebuild now it's
been jarring because you're rebuilding
getting rid of Kahlil macro editing
approached his prime yet the case of
Amari Cooper who's supposed to be a
thousand-yard receiver and he's had
consistency at quarterback so don't know
what's happening there and right on down
the line and this was a team that just
like the Giants they were the playoffs
two years ago so we didn't think it was
a huge reboot and a changeover but both
of these teams
two years time have decided to turn over
the roster so it's a very interesting
look at it let's just put a day this way
I don't know where Oakland's playing
next year because they don't have to
lease for Oakland right now I'm not sure
Oakland wants them back for next year
but they will go into Las Vegas with an
entirely new book yeah no I don't think
there's any question and three
first-round picks in this year's draft
which they need to hit on well they got
hit on all of them right every single
one
look two years ago member when Cleveland
had the three first-round picks I would
say that they've hit on them yeah you
know if you look back all right miles
Garrett Jabril Peppers David and Joe ku
I think all three of those are hits and
then they supplemented it this year with
Baker Mayfield as Denzel Ward you can't
say that the Browns didn't draft good
players before we let you go Charles and
thank you so much for coming on I really
appreciate it
your fav little inside baseball in terms
of your calling games you've been doing
it far longer than I have and one of the
one of the cooler parts is that you get
this time to sit down with with the
coaches and the players and these
production meetings who are your
favorite guys coaches players too and
you're not exactly chopping it up all
the time and production meetings so
they're all different but sometimes you
do who are your favorite guys to sit
down with and you and just listen to I
was lucky enough that I came in before
Favre exited but as far as the only
player ever it did I dealt with in an
NFL production reading that you had won
and I say that with admiration not with
any type of a shot or anything like that
Brett liked hanging out and I remember
someone from Minnesota told me you gotta
understand
everyone knows Brett Favre and you know
how difficult that is in football guys
football guys aren't recognized the same
way other than their size like other
like basketball players and even
baseball players because the helmet you
know the face is people always go that's
somebody who and by then the moments
back but Brett was recognizable so he
didn't go out to dinner on the road
he stayed in he hung so you just like to
hang out chop it up with the guys so how
lucky was I as a young broadcaster
here's Brett Favre with his feet up
telling us stories you know for the game
but just hang in with Brett Favre
so it's hard to beat that especially for
me at the time I was in and I'll leave
you with this an Alec oval tree who I I
will see at some point this weekend now
with the the Giants he's with the Rams
he went to Georgia James you may not
know this but dan and I both went to
Tennessee I had the Rams a couple years
ago Tennessee Georgia weak neck so Alec
came in with a big grin on his face like
yellow Davis because he's a little bit I
know I know the game and about halfway
through we're talking having a good time
asking him questions you knows me and
the rest of the crew like just being him
and someone from the Rams pop their head
in and went oh Alec real quick Tennessee
just beat you that was that game and I
didn't have many of those he goes what
the guy said yeah they throw a Hail Mary
the end zone and they just could they
just said it's good Tennessee went
[Laughter]
mostly we have some more of those those
are fun Charles Davis one of the best in
the business out of percent as I said my
partner in the preseason with the Titans
working for Fox and NFL Network right
now also also my son would be the first
to remind me that is the voice of
Madinah color analyst on Madden and it
is that's you do you get recognized as
much for Madden now as you do for
anything else not as much as one would
expect because myself and Brandon God my
partner were barely in the game like we
pop up on like the third quarter like
our faces pop up and I think everybody
but ins right through like those know
why
so but but every week in a production
meeting around a team no exaggeration at
some point someone will make a reference
to the Madden game whether it's actually
playing it or that guy last week with
unbelievable who's like something out of
Mad and something along those lines
occasionally guys know who I am a lot
less than you would think well what an
amazing franchise to be a part of and
you know he also sent my my son of
Madden games thank you for that my
friend hey have a great call with with
my Redskins and the Giants coming up
this weekend for your sake I just hope
it's a good game in the burgundy and
gold come on top I have a feeling that
we will have a good game it's that type
of rivalry the Giants have their pride
stung win and everybody thinks it's a
fire sale those types of teams tend to
come out and play pretty hard so I
expect it to be that type of the game
and James well I sure you abandoned me
at the seminar man two years ago last
year you're like no way I'm doing this
again so I expect to see you next year
if I'm coming back okay hey there you go
I like it man good one of the best of
the business Charles Davis thank you
very much the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience